don't do this priest it's gonna cost you
man no no
Bad Bunny slammed through a table on
Monday Night Raw I was so crazy so how
did the singer get from this today I'm
just enjoying
like a fan so
[Applause]
it's all because Bad Bunny got involved
in Dominic Mysterio's match against his
father Rey Mysterio
[Applause]
and that's when things turned ugly fast
I did the right thing see yeah
[Music]
then wrestler Damien priest entered the
chat and took matters into his own hands
oh no
don't do this priest Damian priest
don't do it don't do this priest it's
gonna cost you man no oh my God
in his truck can you guys hear me get
somebody out here buddy buddies hurt I
always put my my a piece of my heart on
everything that I do music I love
wrestling since ever since since I was a
kid in my songs I have a lot of
wrestling reference one of those
formed at his very first WWE event
soon
then bad bunnies made his way into the
ring a handful of times including WWE's
biggest event WrestleMania
[Music]
[Applause]
right I wanna be on the ring I wanna
fight but real were you nervous were you
scared at all by
I was I really was that day I'm not 100
sure but I think that the best day of my
life that
bring wrestling back to his home country
of Puerto Rico by hosting backlash I'm
very happy to be the host of backlash in
my Island Puerto Rico finally WWE is
back to Puerto Rico I'm very happy
everyone come do whatever you you you
have to to believe sound like cheesy
like but you have to believe yourself
and and work
um always with confidence and
believe and work is the key as far as if
bad Bunny's also going to wrestle that's
TBD but we wouldn't be surprised if he
did what do priests of buddy I plan oh
priest over there
[Music]